because it does say the bus driver's hot
so yeah he probably knew that dude was
going to pass out though bro because
they don't have AC in the box
is my moment
[Music]
we got a heroic tale about a seventh
grade kid who happened to be on a school
bus when the bus driver just passed out
and started oh I saw this it was like a
really hot I got a heart attack was it a
heart attack or something like it just
said he passed out because it was like
really hot and stuff like that maybe
there's a development bus driver was
sexy I just made that up
he said the bus driver was really hot
yeah oh yeah yeah I think I read that
too actually yeah smoking hot that's
what I meant here's the video so you saw
himself in the mirror he's like God damn
oh [__]
oh wait this is a different one oh [__]
all right the thing that makes I saw a
different one the one with the black
dude right yeah
why don't you guys pull that up and we
can change the video
it's the same thing it's the same store
but that one comes up we're trying to
dodge black Excellence bro yeah what's
going on huh but that one's form
s recent yeah it's more of course it
would be a white man that we're talking
about so the thing that made this
interesting is in the um post-game
interview uh of everything that went on
it was that all the kids were like on
their airpods on their phones playing
games on social media stuff like that so
nobody was really paying normal kitchen
one kid who wasn't on his phone probably
a weirdo too huh probably probably reads
books the [__] nerdy Eagle Scout I
bet he's he's the same Rhymes
the sad thing is his parents can't
afford airpods oh [__] oh so he starts
spazzing out again oh my God that's
right when he saw himself yeah oh [__]
that's not good
oh no and the bus is moving oh my God
bro we gotta get these bus drivers
healthy oh [__]
we're at the king I feel it's like a
teacher
whoa that's something
[Music]
Bravo to his parents
not boo his parents
[__] his parents dude his spirits are
soft you know what his parents never
appreciated him anyway
get him some real pair is this the one
though where his parents said like he's
been driving since he was like four or
five arrested there was one there was
one of these things where like Chris's
parents were teaching them too early
driving like on the Open Fields oh yeah
I don't know if this is the one I've
heard about that that's like a thing
right if you live on a farm yeah yeah a
permit that lets you drive for tasks you
hear about that oh I didn't know it was
like a private property I thought you
just I thought you just did it yeah but
I think it's private property I think
you can yeah private property but you
can even go on the road if you if you
have a phone oh okay you could even go
to like get stuff I let taika drive
shut the [__] up all right we got him
move it move it move it
yeah like behind behind my house is a
bunch of just [__] desert so so I was
like we're gonna take we're gonna take
the dogs to [__] run around and then
I was like hey you want to drive and
guess what he said the truck yeah he
said yes no way he said yes
what an amazing child
yeah and he was driving he reached the
gas pedal no I had to press the gas
pedal but I let him turn he's not trying
she's thinking of the truck are you you
know the electric ones
450 miles on one charge see
but it's never gonna come out this thing
yeah yeah I trust that woman's CEO at GM
wow who is she I thought about the Cyber
truck no no no the Silverado uh no I
want the Cyber truck I put my pre-order
in like oh that one yeah we don't know
we don't know
sorry to derail this but anyway yeah
back to the white kid that saved the day
the boy's stepmother uh basically told
reporters that her son knew how to stop
the bus because he had watched the
driver do it every day I guess what a
weirdo dude I guess he's just paying
attention but it is dope I'm just
kidding it is dope when you want to
murder the bus driver there's no
hesitation yeah you know what I mean he
just goes straight in puts his foot on
the stock you know it's calm too yeah it
was a free it's almost like he knew this
would happen
but you know the thing is though is you
know because the mom said the Stepmom
said that he he had watched the bus to
ever do it before and then he jumped
into action which means he was watching
the bus driver the entire time that is a
little because it does say the bus
driver is hot so yeah but it's true
smoking even spoken air quote he
probably knew that dude was gonna pass
out though because they don't have AC in
the box
is my moment the next time you go to a
bus right the poor Buster ever got this
tiny little ass fan I know who is that
gonna help yeah nobody especially one
thing after a bunch of these kids just
do you think that every chick on that
bus owes him a [__]
no because that guy
everyone at seventh grade or what 12
years old well you could cash it in
later
but you know what though
yeah it doesn't look fire it's range you
know you know what though I think I
think in this day and age that may
happen in junior high I think in ninth
grade sure dude kids are sucking each
other off for sure oh my God honestly I
don't believe this kid was like was very
popular in his class yeah it didn't look
like it because he's sitting at the
front of the bus he's got it everyone
knows well but as everyone knows only
the cool kids sit in the back those
friends aren't Gonna Last either too
that kid was in the front probably and
he's watching the bus driver he had no
air Paws he had no gaming unit he's just
sitting there all he has to do is watch
the bus tracker yo if that if that kid
was in the back
deserves what eagle eyes man
do you guys remember any defining
because I'm assuming this guy goes to
school for the next like two years and
he's like a g like I don't think that
that's gonna be you know what I mean did
you guys ever recall a moment junior
high or high school where maybe you did
something and your social status changed
yeah you had mentioned like [__]
whipping some dude's ass into that
change oh that's interesting like losing
to a blind guy in wrestling yeah no well
you were talking about the other the
other story the other day where you like
had to just suddenly get into a fight
you beat that dude up Suddenly It's like
all right Bart's a guy who because you
like transferred to a high school or
something like that yeah that's boring
though okay
nobody
but if you remember back in like Junior
High in high school if there was a kid
that wasn't that popular and then like
one day they did something really cool I
think they would only last a day or two
yeah I don't think that [__] last I
don't even think that really works no I
think when like dorks do cool [__] you
just find a reason to keep calling them
a door yeah yeah yeah yeah
it doesn't really make it like you know
the movies where like dorks become cool
that [__] that was I've never seen
because I feel like kids are haters I've
seen cool kids get way cooler and like
dorky kids just stay dorky yeah yeah it
doesn't really like have you had one
where something happened and it's like
the added to your legacy the rest of
your year
um I was gonna share but now that you
know Ryan said dark people just stay
here I'm like really hesitant now you
call yourself dork you were never dorky
yeah yeah I want to punch you in the
face if you call yourself the first time
yeah everyone's been trying to have sex
with you for a long time the first time
you danced uh I will say that that was
actually a big change because I was you
know how I always talk about like I was
a [__] loser in high school right No
One Believes it No One Believes it I
don't even remember you in high school I
guarantee you guys see photos you got I
believe this all right yeah and photos
maybe but so did everyone else look like
that my point is there was it wasn't
until my
senior year actually that we had like a
kind of like an air bands lip sync
competition oh you know what I'm talking
about you know where like different
clubs have to like compete for like more
points by the end of the year there's a
giant event it's a lip sync for us is
that a cool ass High School bro and then
I remember that was like my first time
doing something public you know what I
mean everything that you do a lot of
times in like high school or whatever
you're either like stay low-key yeah
you're just in your class and your group
of friends whatever it might be your
Clique your clubs but getting on stage
that was my first time getting on stage
and doing like a dance performance for
our lip sync uh with my club that make a
Red Cross what song did you do
so I went to Cerritos High School and I
played I was on a drumline I played
drums and like jazz band whatever and I
remember coming here and Mark couple's
band sucked [__] ass so I remember
going like I don't even want to be a
part of this [__] yeah so I didn't play
drums at all but then I remember senior
year I was like [__] I haven't played
drums a long time I do miss it so I
signed up for the talent show and then I
remember
my drum souls are the stupidest things
so I remember going there just [__]
going ham
and I'll and I and I had like an
out-of-body experience I'm like that was
the [__] whackest [__] because like
it's like there's no beat no one's
grooving to you it's just like kids like
in the audience like
you know what I mean and I was like that
if I could rewind the moment in my life
I would have rewound and not have done
that
hahaha
hey dude I think drum solos are pretty
cool man what did like people say to you
afterwards no no I don't even imagine it
it might have been so neutral cool
drumsticks it just makes a lot of noise
everyone's just like this
you know what I mean like I think
everyone else might have just been like
okay Bart went after the hula hoop guy
and then whenever so like I think it's
just neutral I got you okay but for me
me uh watching me
a little guy
we should be that guy up did everyone
call you Nick Canton
yeah I was like
those are like five ten minutes I'll
never get back in my life
you guys are the crowd like wrap it up
like a five minute solo cheese and
that's a hula hoop guy beginning to end
too I wish it was time travel then we
could all go back and go all right Nick
Cannon no one would get it your favorite
guy
well I mean he is fathering what 12
children from 11 different women dude if
you had another guy playing drums and
you guys are both battling out and then
you went on his drum set and then played
on his drum and then dropped the sticks
oh that'd be an awesome movie okay I
mean did you just double down and do it
again
no one recorded this but did you double
down and just do it again for the next
year it's like oh man here's the drum
guy again yeah yeah
[Music]
laughs